chances are if you're a regular viewer
of youtube fitness
you'll have encountered people crawling
around the floor like monkeys or
throwing themselves in the air in what
they call
movement flows you may have come across
the likes of eido portal
animal flow gmb or vava fitness and
maybe you thought it looked awesome
maybe thought it looked ridiculous but
the question is whether it has something
to contribute
to a holistic health and fitness
approach and how you can get started
so let's take a look so i'm here in
beautiful brill in oxfordshire
to practice some movement training
movement flows but i just want to put it
out there
that i am by no means an expert i'm very
much still learning i've gone through
the
different courses from gmb vava fitness
and
animal flow so i've got an idea but i
just dabble in this stuff
as a supplement to my training which is
what i recommend for everyone so this
can look a whole lot better
but with that said even just
occasionally
doing this stuff i've seen some real
improvements in various aspects of my
fitness and performance
for instance my straight arm handstand
which was always a bit ugly due to
some poor shoulder mobility still has a
long way to go but it's definitely
improved a lot
and that's just from doing some back
bridges some tabletops some crab crawls
barely doing it much at all but just
every now and then and i've seen real
improvements so
yeah i highly recommend that you give
this stuff a go
unfortunately i've not been able to do
much about the infamous british weather
but
at least it's authentic huh so the idea
of movement training is simple that we
should train for movement
rather than for strength mobility or
endurance that is to say that all those
things should be in service of strong
graceful movement patterns
we're merely changing the emphasis edo
patal is considered
a movement guru and was one of the first
to begin advocating this kind of
approach to training
what he calls movement culture he
describes how rather than building big
biceps and lats
he's more interested in collecting moves
whether that's a maltese a planche or an
albertido
either is known to many as the guy who
has been training conor mcgregor
and there are plenty of videos of the
two of them training in unique and
interesting ways floating around the web
he's also known for his florio sessions
that involve him moving gracefully from
one position to another along the ground
edo hasn't really published any specific
guides to his training
the edo portal method can be learned
through direct training via one of his
retreats
via fairly expensive online shootlege or
picked up in snippets from his
interviews and blog posts
from what we can glean we know that edo
uses a three-stage process to acquire
new movements
and feed them into his flow isolation
integration
improvisation he believes that the most
value a new movement or exercise has
is to be gained from that initial
uncomfortable learning stage
so we should keep learning and adding
new movements edo's own movement is
inspired heavily by his background in
capoeira
a common theme among movement
practitioners but it also incorporates
ideas from dance other martial arts
gymnastics yoga and much more
but he's also meticulous in his approach
ido is keen to emphasize the importance
of both pulling and pushing movements
with heavy use of rings and radiation
this is something that's missing from a
lot of other movement training practices
and even things like yoga if all you're
doing is pushing and crawling
then you're only developing those
pushing muscles and not the lats or the
traps which you need to balance
everything out
ido is also slow to introduce new
movement patterns and begins training
new practitioners by getting them to
start spending time in a resting squat
and a dead hang
to build up their mobility then you have
animal flow created by mike
fitch this meanwhile looks very similar
to edo's method at a glance
it likewise involves moving gracefully
from one position to another
but is much more structured as a system
i bought the program to give it a go
myself and learned a number of moves
that could be chained together into
flows
these include many ground-based
locomotion movements like
bear crawls called beast in animal flow
ape crab under switch over switch and
crab reach
many of these are travelling form this
training lacks a hanging element
and likely won't develop that much
hypertrophy there isn't a whole lot to
be found for legs either
but as a supplement to other forms of
training it's immensely beneficial
there are many other forms of movement
training that fall broadly into this
category
as mentioned both gmb and viva fitness
have their own approaches similar to
animal flow
i've tried them both too and found that
they each had something interesting to
offer
vava fitness in particular emphasizes
the importance of finding your own style
and provides a
wide archive of different movements to
choose from
more than that meanwhile is another
offshoot that emphasizes the need for
training outdoors
and teaches practitioners to climb crags
balance along beams
swim and lift logs this introduces the
unpredictability and chaos that comes
from the wild
teaching us to be more hardy and
adaptable i've talked a little about
this in the past but performing a
pull-up from a tree branch for instance
is infinitely richer in stimulus as
compared with a bar
every single branch is different in
thickness bends differently and places
your hands in different relative
positions
you're forced to grip and to brace the
core to compensate and the same holds
true for trail running scrambling
or lifting logs over your head here's
the big difference when you're lifting
weights in the gym you're encouraged to
use
as identical a form as possible every
time you repeat that movement
on the other hand with movement training
and particularly things like mod nat
every single time you practice a
movement is going to be slightly
different keeping you supple
adaptable and versatile
a good example that demonstrates just
how much we need movement in our lives
is a proprioceptive illusion that you've
probably experienced
so say you're walking down some stairs
and you expect there to be another step
only to find you're actually at the
bottom you don't fall but your body has
this horrible shock this kind of judder
the reason for that is that your body is
preparing in advance for what it thinks
is going to be your next movement this
shows just how much goes into something
as simple as walking down steps
but it also demonstrates just how much
information we're cutting off from
ourselves by wearing thick shoes
and by walking on pavements all the time
when you walk on a flat tarmac floor in
thick
shoes all the time you can literally
switch off from that sense just as you
might tune out
the ticking of a clock in the background
and over time those sensors become
duller so practicing moving in different
ways even if you're not going to become
a
barefoot trail runner it's just so
extremely beneficial for you
was created by irwin lacour who was an
early practitioner of parkour
parkour free running can themselves be
considered as examples of movement
training
and they have their roots in the ideas
of georges hebert who introduced the
world to the natural method or
le method naturale and began the trend
of using assault courses to train
military personnel
georges is the real granddaddy of both
parkour
and movement training and i find it
fascinating watch the evolution of
movement training starting from that
thread
we can view parkour and free running as
different styles of movement training
just as we see different styles in
martial arts mauve nap branches off
slightly sooner
whilst the ideas of mike fitch and edo
portal offer a unique spin on george's
even functional training has its roots
in the natural method
and one of the most amazing things about
movement training in general is the way
that it can borrow the most beneficial
movements and patterns
and stances that we see cropping up time
and time again across different
disciplines
yoga dance martial arts and more these
movements repeat themselves throughout
history
because they're the ones that work for
the human body because they're strong
powerful or challenging
but there's no right way to train
movement the key is simply to move
and to practice learning new movements
rather than focusing purely on getting
stronger in a handful of movements
that you chose years ago the idea is to
express yourself and to find your own
movement style but whatever form of
movement training you pick
whichever movements you gravitate
towards this will have tremendous
benefits for you
the fact of the matter is that what we
do in the gym often fails to mimic the
way we use our bodies
in the real world while being able to
squat to bench and deadlift big numbers
is impressive in its own right
and has a lot of benefits it still
involves moving through that constrained
controlled and predictable movement
pattern
meanwhile in sports and in life we're
required to leap off of one foot
change direction quickly stoop to catch
a ball or contort our bodies in the
transverse plane
to resist at an attempted grapple we
carry our children on our backs up steep
hills we lift prams into boots
in short real life is unpredictable and
so we need to learn to move outside of
repetitive
predictable movement patterns straight
line patterns
this is why the emphasis in movement
training is so often not just the
movements themselves but the transitions
between them
that's where the flow happens and it's
why positions like the lizard crawl that
are extremely compound
and require strength and proprioception
in unusual places from the multifidus
that we talked about recently to the
obliques and transverse abdomini
are so valuable the benefits here are
similar to those found in a kettlebell
flow for example
once again you're strengthening the
positions in between that often get
overlooked
thus becoming more adaptable to any
scenario what's more is that the very
process of learning movements
changes the way that we approach
training and forces a more cohesive
approach
for example in order to learn to planche
we must also learn to control scapular
protraction
and retraction we must learn to hold the
core in that rigid position
and we need to develop a lot of wrist
mobility that's another great thing
about practicing these movements
they include inherent mobility this
means that you don't need to actively
stretch in order to develop and maintain
a greater range of motion
you're simply maintaining that limbo
ability to move by constantly requiring
yourself to do so
it's an ideal antidote to a mostly
seated lifestyle
by making your movements as varied and
complex as possible you avoid losing
range of motion
as much as possible and it's much more
fun than just stretching
it's also possible that all this
multi-planar movement is really good for
your fascia
but that's something that's a a bit
contentious because there's still a lot
of research that needs to be done into
fascia
and b something i'm going to address in
more detail in future videos so stay
tuned for that
finally learning new movements itself
has tremendous benefits for the brain
the process of learning movements
especially complex ones
triggers the release of bdnf brain
derived neurotrophic factor
and other plasticity stimulating
chemicals
learning a new movement is an extremely
immersive form of learning as you must
consider input from all your senses
whilst training new neural pathways
this very process of learning helps to
keep the brain young and plastic
it may even help to develop the
cerebellum which we use in all kinds of
higher order cognitive processes
something to keep in mind is that
although there is a set way to perform
animal flow or gmb for instance there's
no set or correct
way to perform movement training all
movement training really means
is that you're continuously adding
movements to your repertoire you're
experimenting and learning with movement
and you see people
with completely different movement
styles and i find that so inspiring so
don't be
necessarily led by someone you like try
and adapt what you see into something
that's unique to you
[Applause]
[Music]
don't totally copy me you should copy a
little bit me then more create
yourself they'll be coming your way
and it's most important is not
the best you have to be yourself and
this has so many benefits from bdnf and
plasticity to body awareness and
proprioception
and to building those small supporting
muscles and a powerful core that it's
really hard to argue with that that said
i certainly view this type of training
as a supplement or addition
to a well-rounded program i don't think
your workout should be made from 90
cartwheels and downward dog i recommend
adding movement training as a way to
improve mobility proprioception and
control
while using other modalities to develop
your speed explosiveness
max strength etc it works particularly
well as a warm up or a cool down
or something you can do on your rest
days so that's a basic introduction to
movement training what it can do for you
now i know that many of you might be
wondering how you can get started with
this type of training
it's actually very difficult because
there's a lot of conflicting views and
very few actual guidelines or
instructions that you can follow online
and because that's something that i
found myself when trying to learn i
compiled a list of the most common
movements that you see used by a lot of
people
when practicing movement flows i'll put
a link to that in the description down
below and it'll take you to the bioneer
website
we can see all the moves laid out with
descriptions plus a bunch of tips that
you can use to start seeing results much
sooner
if you want to learn how to combine this
kind of dynamic movement into a fully
integrated multimodal program for body
and mind then be sure to check out my
ebook and training program
super functional training that's a huge
pdf that combines everything i talk
about on this channel and goes into even
greater depth resulting in a program
designed to develop every aspect of your
performance there's a link to that in
the description as well
and there's a discount on right now
while we're all dealing with this
coven thing so thanks to time for
watching this one guys i hope you found
it useful and interesting if you did
then please leave a like and share
around
that helps me out immensely i massively
appreciate all of your support
subscribe if you want to see more like
this and of course i'll see you next
time
bye for now i put my hand
in a poo pretty sure